las palabras de joe biden que
anticipaban una nueva escalada de
tensión entre ambos países sobre todo en
el momento en el que dentro de la
entrevista con la cadena abc
el presentador preguntó al presidente si
consideraba a putin un asesino así lo
creo respondió el presidente
norteamericano la reacción de rusia no
se ha hecho esperar el presidente de la
duma estatal rusa el equivalente a la
cámara baja del parlamento ruso
viácheslav volodin ha calificado las
palabras del líder estadounidense sobre
putin como un insulto a los rusos y una
histeria fruto de su impotencia
boldin ha escrito en su canal de
telegrama que putin es el presidente de
rusia y que cualquier ataque contra él
son ataques contra el país el kremlin
considera ya los estadounidenses
impredecibles y por eso avisado de que
tiene en cuenta todos los posibles
escenarios ante la actitud que vaya
mostrando su principal rival geopolítico